tomorrow thank you for that you keep an
eye on who's coming into that number 10
daughter well I'll speak to the shadow
foreign secretary David Lammy who's
joining us now live good morning to your
channel foreign secretary
um and thanks for being with us this
morning so you've now now seen the back
of Boris Johnson what are you expecting
from this trust
well look if she governs the country
like she campaigned I think we're in for
a very turbulent timed unfunded tax cuts
that would continue a low growth economy
um and basically benefit the wealthy and
not those who are working and
particularly those who are poor
um and of course big issues that people
are facing in the Health Service getting
a GP appointment
waiting for operations big issues in our
education system where I'm afraid School
slices have grown and there's a big
difference emerging between London and
parts of the Northeast for example and
crime soaring across our country these
are very big issues some of it did not
come up in the leadership campaign what
we saw was Liz trust tacking to the sort
of never right regions of her party and
not really addressing issues in the
country and if that's how is going to
govern then I think we're in for a very
tough time indeed yeah and a misle I
mean you'll know that there is a support
package that's due to be announced in
the next few days
hundreds billions of pounds being spent
and a possible freeze to energy bills
which is exactly the policy that labor
was suggesting so you must be happy with
that plan
well we first called for a windfall tax
back in January it took the
conservatives months and months and
months to copy our policy and adopt it
we've called for a freeze I welcome uh
Liz truss
damage and conversion if she adopts our
policy but the devil will be in the
detail is she in fact going to burden
the general public with higher bills in
the years ahead and get the money that
way which I think would be grossly
unfair and not benefit The Wider economy
or is she going to do what we've said
which is ensure that the North Sea oil
at high profits that they've made
profits that they weren't predicting
actually contribute to freezing those
bills that's the detail that we'll need
to see over the coming days
and that's the key word you do there
isn't it contribute because as you know
that windfall tax that you've suggested
won't get anywhere near the scale of the
amount of money that's needed
well in fact I think our proposal was
for the next six months uh that was the
emergency period that we were addressing
and we costed our proposal what I what's
been speculated in the media is that
this trust has a plan for two years uh
which is obviously a lot more money and
that's why we're seeing money above 100
billion but look these are her plans uh
we will scrutinize those plans very
intently but look the debate now is not
about supporting the general public I
think labor have driven that debate and
the conservatives accept that people
need that support and I'm glad to see
Liz trust coming with us the key issue
is who pays
is it ordinary working people or is it
those with the broadest shoulders and
talking about unfunded tax cuts talking
about a reduction in corporation tax all
suggests that her interests are actually
uh with those the wealthy and she's
going to make those who are working pay
for it and that's what we will be
opposing that's the dividing line in
politics at the moment yeah and we'll
find out exactly how they do propose to
pay for it in the next couple of days
we've been promised and you'll hear the
noises office you'll know that cabinet
is about to begin so some of those new
cabinet members are arriving as we speak
and I want to get your comments on
the top team that lives trust has
assembled for his office the most
diverse top team it's ever been seen at
the top of government
look I welcome the fact that we are a
multi-ethnic multicultural country it's
a journey that began under Tony Blair
with the appointment of people like
Valerie Amos Patricia Scotland Paul
botang and it continued with David
Cameron who brought on a generation of
these people who are now in the cabinet
and and indeed he asked me to do a
review so I welcome that labor remains
committed to these issues where the
natural party I think of diversity in
our country I think we've got a higher
percentage of MPS that come from an
ethnic background but I think all of us
can celebrate a multi-ethnic Britain
it's the Britain by the way that one is
the Olympics back in 2012. it's good to
see it mirrored in the conservative
party at this time
I'm glad you did mention David Cameron
and all to Tony Blair there because it
it was a lot of his moves to try and get
more um gender diverse uh more
ethnically diverse people into those
positions and that kind of helped get us
to where we are here but I don't want to
say this is not a partisansan issue at
all no exactly exactly not it's part of
the kind of country that we want to be
and outward facing inclusive country
that has reached all over the global
community and that's why by the way I
texted James cleverley and quasiquitang
yesterday we have good cordial
relationships and I congratulated them
on their appointment
and I'm sure they'll be very happy to
hear that for you miss Levy but I do
want to take you a little bit further on
this because then what responsibility to
having that diverse top team have for
those communities that they they
represent at the very top where we
haven't seen people like that before
well as I say I mean I do think we've
seen diversity
um in the cabinet but clearly
quasi-cratang's appointment and James
cleverly uh is important because these
are Big offices of State
all of us need Role Models whatever our
background uh and I and I hold that dear
particularly
for working people uh white and black
that need to see role models that look
like them are young people uh in public
life and so as I say I think we
celebrate this and I'm very pleased to
see big offices of State uh going to
these individuals and representing the
kind of country
um that we want to be recognizing that
there are many other countries within
the Democratic Western tradition that
have not arrived at that diverse place
yet
uh well just follow on from that then so
what does it tell us about Britain
particularly that we have managed to
arrive at this point as you put it
it reminds us that Britain uh is a
country with a history that reaches all
across the globe I think it reminds us
that we've now been on a journey really
since the Windrush generation came to
this country uh post the second world
war and and you start to see that second
third generation uh uh exceeding but I
think it also tells us that there's more
to do because that is not replicated
across every sector of our country we're
seeing it in politics in some ways
because of Acts of positive
discrimination by both the labor party
and indeed by David Cameron when he was
leader of the conservative party so I
think there's more to do but of course
we've got to welcome the diversity that
we're seeing in the current cabinet